[Musique]
on est en direct on est avec big flo et
oli qui vont être avec nous pendant
toute l'émission qu'est-ce que je suis
pourtant devoir parce que on sait pas vu
en fait cessé d'être heureuse et fière
vous savez qui est exceptionnel merci la
véranda c'est bon ça va mais celle
évidemment je suis fan mois-là absolue
je sais qu'il a plein qui vont regarder
l'émission
ce qui habite flow lice ce soir ya syfy
ya paix fille à fille qu'elle a regardé
est allé à petit les sous louer un peu
la fiq et lamouchi way you grosse grosse
équipe ce soir
franchement on est on est comme si on
s'arrête la folie est hélas hélas il ya
des gens qui sont venus nous voir voilà
c'était des amis à kelly ya jean luc
voilà bonsoir merci merci d'être là
bravo pardon pour tout ce que vous
faites merci des flots allez on va se
retrouver dans un instant et ils vont
chanter en plus avec nous ce soir les
gars je vous kiffe de ouf
comment je veux qu'il joue bien
qu'est-ce que sa voisine qui vient faire
ici attention à dire bonjour
attention pierre weiss pierre noire dont
on attend la suite au choc le bar 1 0 à
3 cm pour te vois ce tennis pierre
pigeau pierre feuille ciseaux pierre
feuille ciseaux et oui j'ai baptisé
merci
les deux frères j'ai déplié ça c'est
fait ça c'est réglé tu fais un petit
pierre feuille ciseaux m'a dit attention
un petit air de 6 ou 3 soins attention
les gars les gars vous les voulez qu'on
fasse un petit pari à mais là on dirait
que ça va vas-y tu sais quoi sans
déconner vas-y attend jamais de la
corbeille de fruits
enfin pierre feuille ciseaux corbeille
de fruits
ok michelin ou abonnés à mal l émission
a commencé à bien sûr qu'elle a comme au
ciné club
celui qui perd celui qui perd celui qui
perd il doit manger cette banane en
entier en moins de 5 secondes d'accord
ok
quoi sinon j'en choisirai qui va le
faire contre moi ce sera toi qui va
faire le premier pierre feuille ciseaux
c'est toi merci à toi lui dit pierre
fugain pierre hier
non non bien faire la fête pierre
feuille ciseaux pierre feuille ciseaux
ses bras allez c'est parti
cinq secondes attention bonsoir bonsoir
et merci d'être là vas-y mon chéri sinon
attention c'est que je veux aller plus
vers eux deux trois quarts ça s'est
inversé caméra qui gagne on ne rejoue
pas être la nourriture merci c'est parti
alors on en fait un deuxième on enfin
deuxième attention pour l'album ce que
je propose c'est ce qu'on fait là alors
c'est très simple on fait c'est
l'émission ouais on fait le jeu de la
paix mais fait le jeu de la pêche
d'accord quelqu'un va mais voilà
quelqu'un va frotter cette brèche contre
son corps il faudra la croquer ensuite
l'équipe r le père paul 6 et toi c'est
bon toi contre moi c'est parti
fifi tut l'affrontera contre le corps
très heureux père pal
pierre feuille ciseaux y ait faute la
protège contre le corps vas-y les
aisselles les et samarie respect qu'ils
rêvent ils respectent arrière pays les
bons joueurs elle regardait quand même
il a regardé quand même une grande
émission c'est une grande émission c'est
ma part tu adores dès mardi
tu en perds un dernier sur la tête de ma
mère
celui qui perd il doit manger le réseau
monde entier avec la branche est lui
allé partout c'était pas du tout imprévu
cette merde attention
pierre feuille ciseaux tu le manges
direct au tennis ou à il échoue la
moitié c'est bon non pas la moitié c'est
bon wen mais c'est rien
il est obligé de la vallée pour
continuer l'émission